yeah I have here yanish she with me
welcome Yan we haven't seen you for all
these days how did it go for you first
of all s Louis rapid and Blitz event you
were fighting till the very end yeah I
wasn't I wasn't doing great
um I mean yeah I have nothing to proud
of rabbit and biss I think even despite
this like hor starts in rapit I could
all the chances to you know
to to win it all in B but yeah also got
like I think I was a little bit too
careless in the first day like losing uh
last two games without U um a good
reason to do this to do so
so
yeah um I ended up like sharing first
place yeah but of course I'm I'm
disappointed uh yeah so also I was B I
felt you know a little bit unwell maybe
some cold uh the second day of brid so
yeah now I'm trying trying to recover
yeah the what what do you think was The
crucial moment when you lost your
chances to fight for the victory in the
tournament which game was let's say the
most important for you well uh I think
it was very close to the very end yeah
but uh yeah
clearly I think uh losing to fuja who
played awfully that day but he only
played a good game against me and yeah
also I think it was um like a direct
encounter with Fabiano so I was a little
bit lucky to win the first game but yeah
the second game yeah uh I think I played
purly and um yeah uh you know it was a
little bit too late and I saw that
actually he's also fighting for some
places I thought it's like two horse
races they say like me and Maxim but
then okay I saw like some some other
guys are also like taking
joining yeah yeah so now we are already
started the sful cup time time flies and
today you played against Rich raer uh
the interesting fact is that rich was
traveling I think you know about it from
W he didn't come also for the technical
meeting yesterday did you try to take
have you thought about it to try to get
take advantage of the fact that Richie
just came from vwa and let's say maybe
not in the best shape well like maybe it
would be some uh some wise thing to do
but uh as for me I more focused on
myself uh so yeah it's still like the
recovery is like I know I'm
Midway um to
like recovering from the cold so I think
it's uh it's a question who was in WEA
shape yeah I guess I guess uh yeah it's
could of course he could pick like a
different line like to make it more
complex but I think he pretty much
repeated the game I had the game I
played against vland this year in um in
Dubai mhm uh so was one of my few good
games that went but it was more or less
all prep so yeah so until which moment
it was your preparation the varant or
well I think you played even one move
today to be honest to be honest I think
the vishi at this position I might be
mistaken but weish should played here
Rook
E5 and it was like Rook E2 Rook E5 like
check King G2 Bishop B2 and yeah also
leads pretty much to the same to the
same thing yeah same structure uh like
opposite color Bishops and um yeah we we
know it's it's not so eventful yeah I
understand so now just last question for
you now that the single cup has started
who do you think will fight for the
first places in this turnour for the top
especially now knowing the shape of the
players from St Louis rapid and blad
also okay we have some new players but
so what is what do you think about it I
think I will
good TR that's a good on this really
optimistic note let me finish this
interview all the best of luck for you
Yan thank you and we go back to the
studio thank you Anastasia well another
guy in studio p